oh another ufo segment that's crazy
you'd have to be crazy to believe that's
possible really is it any crazier than
what's coming out of say your average
white house briefing no it really isn't
so with that in mind
a fascinating conference today about
ufos and nuclear weapons that took place
in washington added a u.s air force
captain called david shindelli said he
was part of an incident in which a ufo
disabled 10 nuclear icbm missiles here's
part of what he said
there has been a long history of ufo
incidents and encounters with much
investigation of them from 1947 and even
earlier in september of 1966
i was a man icbm launch control officer
and deputy commander of a launch crew
stationed at minot air force base north
dakota
i was involved in a ufo incident at that
time
where a flying object tampered with
and took down a total of 10
nuclear-tipped icbm missiles
by rendering them
unlaunchable tom rogan is one of the
rare serious journalists actual
journalists in washington who's been on
this story for years in a very rigorous
way he's a columnist now with the
washington examiner he was following the
conference today he joins us tonight for
a recap tom thanks a lot for coming on
so what did you learn today at this
event
thanks tucker yeah i think the key point
here is that although these gentlemen
have been
telling their stories for a while
now they are doing it in a fashion where
they can finally be taken seriously by
more people and unfortunately though
there weren't that many journalists
there today but there were more perhaps
than there have been i think the key
point though is that uh people with some
of the highest security clearances at
the height of the cold war for the u.s
air force
multiple different individuals at
multiple different sites across a period
of decades
say that ufos interacted with nuclear
weapons platforms
and either rendered them inoperable or
took them offline
and so something was done by a a
technological force as these uh officers
would suggest uh that cannot be
explained and and that in and of itself
surely should be
big news worthy of serious further
investigation
well by definition any force that can
take america's nuclear weapons offline
is something you need to worry about
presumably the pentagon has been looking
at this assessed it have they
given any any indication of what they
think happened
what's i think unfortunate and i guess
we're at the start of a process you know
the the director of national
intelligence had this report but what's
unfortunate is that the government does
know that there is a nuclear connection
they've kept that classified uh frankly
i can understand why some of it is
classified but they should come clean
with a lot more uh that they know i mean
the simple fact right the u.s navy why
does the navy keep seeing these things
with the aircraft carriers well aircraft
carriers are nuclear-powered
why do submarines see them nuclear
connection
this nuclear missile incidence from the
cold war
there's credible testimony from a great
historian uh on this robert hastings who
wrote about ufos and nukes to suggest
that the soviets had similar experiences
yeah something is going on here it's not
america it's not china it's not russia
and we need to get a grip and take it
seriously instead of laughing it off as
an issue for crazy people
right i mean there are a lot of crazy
people in this world right now i i would
say the people who take this seriously
may be among the least crazy in our
public conversation you're certainly in
that category tom rogan appreciate you
coming on tonight and covering this
thank you
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else